four numbers are to be selected from the
set of the first eight positive integers
toys wherever you can you put out the
sample space and you do it in the
simplest way you can first they are
positive integers I can just list that
up okay so one two three okay so in the
scheme of this thing right and objects
case spots to fill this is eight objects
right so I'm just gonna write for myself
and equals eight
off the bat okay the question continues
before numbers are to be selected so
there's my box of four okay find how
many possible combinations there's our
keyword right there are if there are no
restrictions okay so this is really easy
to start with right I have got no
restriction there's nothing to worry
about so I just think well I've got
eight things and I'm going to put them
into four spots
I want to choose four of them and I
worry about the order okay say choose 4
well you can treat you calculator I
suppose but I'm just gonna gonna do as
much as I can over here okay let's see
eight factorial on now I'm gonna have K
factorial n minus K per trillion blowing
that's full factorial factorial okay so
if let's see I'm gonna get 8 by 7 by 6
by 5 on 4 by 3 but you buy one is that
it came one of my full factorials
cancelled I can cancel that I can cancel
that that looks to me like 17 yeah
it's okay I don't expect you to do that
however just as a helpful note it's
really good to have these in the back of
your mind as you do them and don't just
get your condition to align your
calculator to work those out when you're
doing identities all right kind of thing
it's really helpful to be able just go I
know exactly what that stands for okay
and this is the way that that practiced
so so many ways no problem let's start
to add some conditions in you there are
two odd numbers and two even those okay
so now I have to restrict a little bit
let's think about it one step at a time
first I want to pick a pair of odd
numbers okay so you have a look at your
sample space and you think how many odd
numbers are there and the answer is
there are 4 1 2 3 4 so now instead of n
being 8 right for this situation I'm
just picking from odd numbers right I
only get to choose strong for right now
how many do I pick I want to pick two of
them okay great so now picked out those
two what I do with others well look at
my even numbers and I repeat the process
right now pause for a second we're
thinking about this under the context of
probabilities right sir I know that for
the evens there's gonna be four and then
I have to choose two of them again okay
but in between here am i adding or am i
multiplying and the answer is I am
multiplying I'm not adding but the
question is why because how will you be
able to tell when it's a bit tricky
right how do you know that it is
multiplication or not tradition where do
we use addition and when do we use
multiplication when do the practical
addition rule come in in terms of
probability yeah you can either think in
terms of independent and dependent
events or the way that I have catched up
in class has been either simultaneous
events or not simultaneous events okay
now here's the thing you want to end up
with four numbers at the end right so
you need these two and these two at the
same time you don't have all four then
you don't have the
for numbers that you were meant to come
up with so being you have to have them
at the same time that's why I multiply
all right
let's see 4 choose 2 so we're gonna have
to reach for a calculator on this one I
think this is on 4 times 4 times 3 times
3 times 1 because one of my two
factorials is cancelled
that's I'm going straight to this time
that's 6 and then you're doing it again
so 2 36 36 ways that makes sense this
should be far less ways to do it
the Miss this is our being sort of
sample space if you like and now I'm
restricting so by the way let's just
quickly turn this into a probability
question right this is not that hard
suppose four numbers out of these are
picked at random what would be the
probability that two are odd and - I
even in the answer is look favorable
outcomes over sample space so it'd be
thirty six or seven eight does that make
sense to see how then you're gonna use
this in the future let's add another
condition mm-hmm there is exactly one
odd number exactly one odd number
okay I've walked you through these ones
in the ways that I set them up how would
you like to suggest I set up this one
okay sir hold on I heard 4c one over
here why why four see one okay so I've
got four odd numbers to choose wrong
right but I only want one of them I
don't I don't want a pair I don't want
it just free-for-all okay I've got a
pick just one and then of course you've
got the other even numbers but you've
got to choose three of them to make up
your form okay so I don't know what that
is I really don't think you end up with
16 ways okay
that's not so hard we're starting to get
the hang of it d this is the slot the
last one
all the numbers must be even all the
numbers must be even so what have you
done what have you done you start to
pick four but then you've just kicked
out all of these options right so now
you only have four to choose from but
you've got a pig or four right searches
for right shoes so what's that goby now
let's just go back to our factorial
notation right this is gonna be 4
factorial on 4 factorial more factorial
more factorials one hold on it's just
one way why is that because because
you've picked all four right now think
back to think back to me over here with
my password right I'm like look if I do
for p4 there's 4 to put in the first
spot 3 and 2 and then 1 so 4 factorial
and I hand over my 4 factorial different
options to you right and then you come
to this situation you're like they're
all the same
you know there's 2 4 6 8 and there's 8
x42 you've given me the same set of 4
even numbers there's only one way really
that you've given me okay does that make
sense to try and transition between the
different nodes
last one hmm read it carefully there is
at least one odd number so this is
similar to the exactly one odd number
but you can have one on number or you
can have two odd numbers or 300 members
or four odd numbers okay so how should
we approach this
any suggestions any stance okay I'm here
I'm hearing someone say a coconut now
hold on but the idea of a compliment
makes sense in in probability because
it's like okay if you've got a
probability of the complement right it's
1 minus the probability of the actual
event right but you don't do 1 minus
here right so what do you do okay so you
think of the whole sample space which we
already worked out it's this guy okay so
therefore the number of ways will be
okay it's gonna be 70 that's my whole
lot - now what is the opposite of the
event they're asking for at least one
odd number the only way to not get at
least one god number is to get 0 odd
numbers that's the only way to get to be
the corner right and we just worked that
out that's getting all the even numbers
right so 70 - now by the way just for
the sake of it right this that was the
smart way you guys are have gotten your
head into the space which is really good
okay
what would because it's not the only way
with these probability and arrangements
questions there's almost always multiple
ways to do it even though it might not
be ideal what would be another way to
approach this you think of different
cases and there are four of them okay
you can go case one one right one odd
number we've done that have a week where
is that that's this one 16 okay what
would be case two
do you want numbers now hold on
haven't we done that one that's here
isn't it let you see it okay case three
now this is interesting
three odd numbers okay we haven't done
this one but we kind of have think about
why okay none of these questions said
what about three odd numbers but they
did say what about three even numbers
and that's exactly the same right
because there's the same number even
numbers it no numbers right picking
three evens this is going to be the same
number of ways to do that as picking
three odds right so this is also going
to be yep there's the last case right
four numbers which again we had not
worked out but we've worked out one
close enough namely for even numbers
same scenario okay and it looks to me I
mean my company's not bad getting this
time okay of course you can see the
complement when I write it out like this
you can see the complement almost sort
of by its absence right what's case fine
in case you're not interested in
no one madness right zero odd numbers
which of course is the compliment that
you worked out before that's the one
which gives you 70 in total your sample
space so they go simple situation let me
just quickly formalize this complement
idea for you right
remember we said picking three odd
numbers is the same as picking three
even numbers right so if you're like
it's kind of like let's think about your
team right so if you want to choose five
people right so you've got you've got
five integers wrong
and you want to pick four of them well
you might as well just say can you
imagine we are any of you you'd like me
that person the schoolyard with you know
the captain from one team and kept the
other pigs out pigs out and you're like
I'm always going to be lost okay I have
the least play powers of the whole
people PR right why didn't you just pick
me first and say I don't want you on my
team that's the same thing isn't it
that's the same picking for people to be
on your teams is exactly the same as
picking one person to not be on your
team right you end up with the same team
don't you okay and of course we know
this binomial because Nck we call this
the symmetrical identity right because
that jerk though we've got this wrong
Pascal it right his triangle is
symmetrical
okay so you can see how this relates to
probability and poor unathletic school
boys the world round okay